Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim
Brettlaff und ich begrüße alle zur 116.
Ausgabe von UKW, eurem Krisenpodcast und heute wenden wir uns mal wieder zu
unserer anderen Dauerkrise zu,
nämlich dem Ukraine-Konflikt und wollen euch dort mal ein Update geben,
was so passiert ist und das mache ich natürlich zusammen mit Pavel. Hallo. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo.
Letztes Mal hatten wir uns ja über Israel unterhalten und dort quasi so ein
bisschen die Basis gelegt dafür diesen Konflikt gegebenenfalls auch regelmäßiger zu begleiten.
Da ist jetzt noch nicht so viel passiert. Deswegen wenden wir uns wieder der
Ukraine zu. Die letzte Sendung hatten wir am 7.
Oktober veröffentlicht, also just an dem Tag, als es dann in Israel losging,
und hatten unter dem Titel Abnutzungskrieg ein wenig davon berichtet,
wie die militärische Lage denn so aussieht.
Ja, und genau da wollen wir jetzt anschließen.
Würde ich sagen, fangen wir auch mal genau mit einer Beschreibung der militärischen Situation an.
Wie war's? Also, wir hatten zuletzt festgestellt, dass die ursprünglich als
Frühjahrsoffensive dann mehr zu einer Sommer-Offensive verrutschten Phase des Krieges.
Prinzip ein wenig ins Stocken gekommen ist. Und dieser Eindruck hat sich jetzt weiter verfestigt.
Das bedeutet, dass an den Hauptvorstoßorten, das sind ungefähr so zwei,
je nachdem wie man drauf schaut, vielleicht auch drei Punkte im Süden der Front,
plus eben der einen Situation um Bachmuth herum, wo also die ukrainische Armee
auf die Russen Druck ausgeübt hat.
Dort sind zwar weiterhin kleine Fortschritte festzustellen, insbesondere um
Bachmuth herum, aber das sind halt solche Gewinne wie, naja,
100 Meter bis ein Kilometer hier und da an einer Stelle der Frontlinie.
Unter größeren Verlusten ist das Ganze auch immer nur erkauft.
Und ja, und auch eben der Hauptvorstoßpunkt Und im Süden Richtung Togmark bei
Robotyne, so da bewegt sich derzeit relativ wenig.
Das Ganze ist halt geprägt von einem Hin und Her. Das bedeutet,
Ukrainer versuchen hier und da mal eine Stellung aufzulösen von den Russen.
Das gelingt ihnen auch. Dann gibt es wieder einen Gegenangriff der Russen.
Dann müssen sie mal wieder ein bisschen zurückgehen. Also das ist sozusagen
dieses typische Wechselspiel,
was eigentlich jeden Konflikt in irgendeiner Form ausmacht oder zumindest solche
kriegerischen Konflikte, die eben mit so einer starken, großen Frontlinie versehen
ist und davon war eigentlich auch von Anfang an immer auszugehen.
Aber der Grund dafür, dass die Ukraine jetzt hier keinen Druck mehr ausüben kann,
liegt vielleicht nicht so sehr daran, dass jetzt irgendwie das Wetter sich groß
geändert hätte, weil sobald ich das sehe, ist jetzt sozusagen diese Regensaison
zwar im Prinzip auf dem Kalender angekommen, hat sich aber noch nicht so ausgewirkt.
Also, weißt du, hast du das Wetter ein bisschen im Blick gehabt, Tobbe?
Ja, es war auch eher warm und aktuell,
schauen wir mal im Vergleich zu uns,
na, kommt schon, ja hier Kramatorsk,
11 Grad Nieselregen und ja für die nächsten 10 Tage ist auch so zwischen Tageshöchsttemperaturen
zwischen 12 und 18 Grad und ja in Kärsonenoblast haben wir sogar 18 Grad und keine Niederschläge.
Da ist also noch recht gemütlich. So Tages-, Nachttiefstemperaturen 10 Grad
und Tageshöchsttemperaturen bis 22 Grad kein Niederschlag.
Ja, das ist so. Aber windig ist es gerade.
Genau, aber wovon ja auszugehen ist, dass das irgendwann eben die Regenfälle
übernehmen und mit diesem lehmigen Boden, den es dort gibt, wird das einfach
schnell in so eine Matschwüste umgewandelt.
Das heißt, jetzt sind noch Vorstöße über die Felder möglich und das wird definitiv
auch eine Zeit hinauslaufen, wo das dann eben so nicht mehr stattfinden kann
und dann ist halt eine andere Art von Stellungskampf angesagt.
Ja, aber bei der bei der Frage jetzt stand der Offensive,
beim letzten Mal hatten wir ja noch festgestellt, sie ist noch nicht zu Ende,
die Offensive, sie läuft noch und ja und sie wurde auch noch nicht für beendet erklärt,
so von niemandem bis bisher, aber Es ist schon nicht so hundertprozentig klar,
ob sie wirklich noch im Gange ist oder ob,
sie eigentlich schon jetzt ihren Höhepunkt überschritten hat und jetzt erst
mal, ja, eine kleinere operationelle Pause hat es ja immer wieder zwischendurch gegeben.
Aber jetzt sieht es im Moment so aus,
als wenn ja in Teilgebieten die Ukraine weiter die Initiative hat,
aber wenn wir auch gleich dazu kommen, in anderen Gegenden versucht jetzt Russland
die Initiative zu übernehmen oder hat sie sogar auch übernommen. Richtig.
Aber man kann auch mal drüber nachdenken woran es halt liegt.
Das hat natürlich immer etwas mit mehreren Faktoren zu tun.
Dazu gehört einfach eine Pause, die du auch vielleicht einfach mal benötigst
um operativ auch mal wieder auf die Beine zu kommen, wenn man permanent alles
durchrotiert und die Soldaten überarbeitet und auch die Logistikkette sozusagen überfordert.
Irgendwann ergeben sich dann halt Risse und das erzeugt nur Fehler.
Das ist halt mal ganz sinnvoll, sich auch einfach mal auf eine Verteidigungslinie
zurückzuziehen, sich darauf zu konzentrieren für eine bestimmte Zeit,
um dann im Hinterland die entsprechenden Ressourcen neu aufbauen zu können.
Das gilt vermutlich auch für Munition, also es gibt zumindest so die Gerüchte,
dass eben die Artilleriebestände, die Artillerie-Munitionsbestände der Ukraine auch,
gut in Anspruch genommen wurden, weil das ist ja einfach in dieser Art Krieg,
die wir dort sehen, ein schwerwiegender Bestandteil.
Also es gilt für beide Seiten. In dem Moment, wo man halt angreifen möchte,
dann läuft es halt nicht selten so, dass eben die Gebiete, die man angreift,
vor allem erstmal mit Artillerie bearbeitet werden.
Ja also man versucht jetzt sagen wir mal 1, 2, 3 Frontlinien,
also diese typischen Grabenlinien, die dann in dieser Gegend in der Regel in
diesen Baumlinien zwischen den großen Feldern besiedelt sind.
Versucht man halt in irgendeiner Form aufzulösen.
Da muss man ja dann erstmal Druck ausüben und das kann man eben machen über
Panzer, das kann man machen über Infanterie.
Diese Techniken verwendet natürlich die Ukraine auch, nur so ein Panzer muss
natürlich auch gut gedeckt sein, damit er nicht sofort von Antipanzerwaffen
auseinandergenommen wird.
Da helfen im Übrigen die Leopardpanzer enorm, wie es den Anschein hat und zwar
gar nicht so sehr, weil sie besser geschützt sind, das auch,
sondern einfach weil sie leiser sind.
Also während man so russische Panzer einfach mehrere Kilometer in der Ferne schon ausmachen kann,
weil die einfach so ein röhrendes Motorengeräusch von sich geben,
sind die Leopardpanzer halt deutlich leiser und können sich halt stellenweise
bis auf wenige hundert Meter an Stellungen heranschleichen, ohne akustisch deutlich
wahrgenommen zu werden. Also das ist so ein Randaspekt.
Trotzdem sind Panzer generell bei dieser ganzen Offensiv-Operation zwar unterstützend
tätig, aber eher aus der Distanz.
Also sie werden derzeit eher so als mobile Artillerie-Geschütze verwendet.
Und streckenweise eben auch dann für Angriffssituationen konkrete,
sind aber nicht so dominant, sondern sehr viel mehr läuft mit Infanterie,
Vehicles, Bradley, Panzer zum Beispiel kommen da viel zum Einsatz,
um einfach schnell Infanterie mit etwas Feuerschutz in die Nähe der gegnerischen
Stellungen zu bringen, dort anzugreifen und im Zweifelsfall sich auch schnell
wieder zurückzuziehen.
Und Panzerschlachten oder Gefechte, überhaupt nur Gefechte zwischen Panzern
kommen nur sehr selten vor.
Also wir haben, glaube ich, ein, zwei gesehen jetzt in den letzten Monaten,
wahrscheinlich gab es ein paar mehr, aber so ist, also Panzer gegen Panzer ist selten.
A. Das ist wirklich die Ausnahme. Aber, und darauf wollte ich ja hinaus,
die Artillerie ist halt einfach hier ein viel wichtigerer Faktor.
Das gilt natürlich speziell für die Ukraine, die ja die präzisere Artillerie
hat und vermutlich auch die deutlich weniger abgenutzte, weil besser gewartete Artillerie.
Also mit den amerikanischen, französischen und deutschen Artilleriesystemen
haben sie eine größere Reichweite und eine höhere Präzision und können damit
natürlich die gegnerischen Stellungen, so sie denn gut ausgekundschaftet sind, gut abdecken.
Und das ist auch so ein Muster, was man sieht. Also es ist definitiv ein Thema
der letzten Wochen und Monate gewesen. Haben wir auch schon darauf hingewiesen,
dass also gezielt Standorte von gegnerischer Artillerie ausgekundschaftet wird
oder welche Fahrzeuge auch immer.
Und dass man dann relativ präzise mit Artillerie dagegen vorgeht.
Und das ist dann eben dieser Abnutzungskrieg, den wir letztes Mal schon beschrieben
haben, in dem jetzt insgesamt...
Keine Fortschritte im Sinne von Landgewinn erzielt werden, aber gegebenenfalls
schon auch messbare Fortschritte in puncto Schwächung des Gegners.
Und das ist halt immer so ein System, man sieht es so lange nicht,
bis das eben so schwerwiegend ist, dass es dann eben auf einmal wieder auch
einen Durchbruch gibt, ne.
Also es passiert immer sehr lange nichts und dann macht es auf einmal Taraa
und die Dinge kommen schnell in Bewegung.
So, aber das ist sagen wir mal so im Wesentlichen jetzt die Situation an dieser
Südfront, was halt abgesehen davon von der puren Gegnerpräsenz schon immer ein Problem war.
An dieser Front sind natürlich Hubschrauber und Minenfelder,
das bleibt auch nach wie vor ein Thema, obwohl gegen Hubschrauber ist der Ukraine
jetzt was interessantes eingefallen, da kommen wir gleich drauf.
Aber schauen wir erst mal auf die russische Gegenoffensive,
denn die gibt es jetzt und zwar ging das dann auch relativ bald,
glaube ich, nach unserer letzten Sendung los, dass die Russen tatsächlich an
mehreren Stellen schon seit längerem hier und da Vorstöße versucht haben.
Das haben wir auch kurz erwähnt. Da war aber nie irgendwie nennenswert, was passiert.
Das gilt auch nach wie vor für den nördlichen Frontverlauf.
Kupjansk und Vysvatovy. Es gibt so verschiedene Stellen,
ungefähr so drei, vier verschiedene Stellen, wo halt die Russen versucht haben,
etwas Druck zu machen, aber nicht in einem nennenswerten Maße,
dass sie nicht mit den vorhandenen ukrainischen Stellungen auch abgefangen werden konnten.
Aber jetzt ging es nochmal richtig los um den Ort Avdivka.
Und Avdivka, das muss man vielleicht mal kurz erläutern, ist eine Vorstadt der Stadt Donetsk.
Donetsk ist ja schon 2014 von den Russen besetzt worden und direkt vor den Stadtmauern,
kann man sagen, verläuft also diese Konfrontationslinie zwischen Russland und
der Ukraine im Prinzip schon seit 2014.
Und da hat auch die neue Offensive so wenig dran geändert, weil die Befestigungen
der Ukraine dort eben schon immer groß waren und sozusagen jetzt fast seit zehn
Jahren ausgebaut werden.
Und keine Stadt drückt das deutlicher aus als eben Avdivka, die zwar jetzt im
Rahmen der neuen Offensive von 2022 dann nochmal mehr unter Angriff genommen
wurde, aber eben bis zum heutigen Tag eigentlich gehalten hat.
Und ja, jetzt gab es so die Vermutung, dass Putin im Hinblick auf den Winter,
wo sich dann wahrscheinlich alles sehr viel mehr eingraben wird,
welche vorzeigbaren Erfolge haben wollte
und offensichtlich eben den Angriff auf Avdivka befohlen hat.
Und naja, das ist wie gesagt einer der am besten befestigten und abgesicherten
Teile des ukrainischen Gebiets dort an der Frontlinie.
Und das heißt natürlich, dass der Aufwand, der hier getätigt werden muss,
um irgendwelche Fortschritte zu erzielen, sehr, sehr groß sein muss.
Und siehe da, auf einmal haben die Russen eine Unmenge an Panzern und sonstigen
Artillerie-Geschützen und Infanteriefahrzeugen zusammengezogen.
Konkrete Zahlen kann ich jetzt nicht nennen, man kann nur so ein bisschen von
den Verlusten auf den Aufwand schließen,
aber es handelt sich hier um hunderte von Fahrzeugen, die hier aufgewendet wurden
und tausende von Soldaten, die also jetzt von zwei Seiten aus Avdivka so einschließen sollen.
Aber ein Einschließen der Stadt wäre dann sozusagen der Gewinn und das ist nicht
gut gelaufen für die Russen bisher.
Also größenordnungsmäßig, glaube ich,
haben sie sowas wie gegen Wert von zehn Battalion Tactical Groups oder BTGs
dort versammelt und man kann davon ausgehen,
dass eben in der Ukraine so von der Größenordnung 100 im Einsatz sind.
Das heißt, die haben so ungefähr 10 Prozent ihrer gesamten Streitkräfte in der
Ukraine wahrscheinlich vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen mehr dort in diesen
Angriff hineingeworfen.
Also Konzentration an Panzern und Fahrzeugen so in die Hunderte geht,
also zwischen 500 und tausend Fahrzeuge haben sie dort konzentriert und ja zwischen
fünf und zehntausend Soldaten und das ist natürlich nicht unentdeckt geblieben.
Das heißt, die Ukraine hat das Tage vorher gesehen,
dass die dort eine ganze Menge an Truppen zusammenziehen und sich dementsprechend
auch vorbereitet auf das,
was da zu kommen schien oder möglicherweise kommen würde, wobei ich, also damit, dass
sie das tun würden, hat wahrscheinlich aber kaum jemand gerechnet,
weil es mal wieder keine besonders intelligente Entscheidung war und nicht besonders
gut ausgeführt. Aber ja, vielleicht.
Kannst du ja dazu was sagen, wie das Ganze dann verlaufen ist.
TROZINSKI Ja gut, wir haben jetzt ungefähr, wie lange läuft das jetzt?
10, 11, 12 Tage ungefähr.
Die Angriffe waren massiv. Also sie sind dann immer so mit so 10,
20 Fahrzeugen auf einmal so an der Kette entlang gefahren. Die müssen in dem
Gebiet dann auch sehr auf die vorhandenen Straßen sich konzentrieren.
Insbesondere im Norden von Avdivka, da gibt es so eine große Abraumhalde,
also Avdivka muss man dazu sagen ist so ein Kohlebergbau Standort und es gibt
dort so einen Berg wo eben die ganzen,
ich weiß nicht ganz genau woraus, ob das nur Abraum ist oder ob das sozusagen
auch noch Abfallprodukte aus der Kohlegewinnung ist,
ich hab da verschiedene Sachen gehört, also auf jeden Fall ist da so ein riesiger
manmade Hügel im Norden dieser Stadt, der also nochmal so eine 25 Meter Höhe
aufweist, über dem restlichen Gebiet.
Generell haben die Ukrainer an der Stelle auch nochmal einen Höhenvorteil.
Das heißt die Russen greifen da im Norden auch aus den Niederungen an.
Und dementsprechend können die das halt gut überblicken. Dazu kommt natürlich
auch noch ihre Aufklärung mit Drohnen und was sie dort noch vielleicht installiert haben.
Auf jeden Fall als diese russischen Angriffe kamen sind also im Prinzip jeden
Tag nahezu alle Fahrzeuge die dort auf die Stellung der Ukraine zugefahren sind,
wurden mehr oder weniger komplett vernichtet mit dem Personal auch.
Also da gibt es einfach krasse Videos wo dann einfach so 10 Fahrzeuge ankommen
und dann macht es bam bam bam bam bam und irgendwie einer nach dem anderen geht in Explosionen auf.
Das ist natürlich immer so eine Sache, das wissen wir auch, mit diesen ganzen
Videos, du siehst halt immer so die einen und die anderen siehst du nicht.
Natürlich gab es auch hier starke ukrainische Verluste bei diesen Kämpfen.
Einfach weil die Russen wieder mit dieser Bachmuth-Methode vorgegangen sind.
Wir schicken einfach alles nach vorne, uns ist doch egal wie viele Leute dabei drauf gehen.
Irgendeiner wird schon durchkommen und dann ist irgendwann besser und wenn das
jetzt ein paar tausend Menschenleben kostet, uns ist doch egal.
Ja, vier. Also man geht davon aus, so größenordnungsmäßig, dass die Russen das
Äquivalent von vier Bataillonsgruppen verloren haben.
Also eine BTG hat halt üblicherweise so was zehn Panzer oder so und 50 Panzer
und 50 andere Fahrzeuge.
Ja und die...
Die letzten Gesamtzahlen, ja, wie gesagt, zig Panzer zerstört auf jeden Fall.
Also 40, 50, 60 und hunderte von Fahrzeugen und tausende von Soldaten.
Und ja, also man kann sagen, dass wahrscheinlich jetzt dieser Angriff auf Avdivka
Russland so fünf Prozent seiner Truppen in der Ukraine gekostet hat.
Innerhalb von 14 Tagen. A.
Und das ist noch nicht vorbei. Also sie probieren es halt nach wie vor.
Mittlerweile machen sie auch Fortschritte.
Dieser Hügel, Terikon wird der dort genannt, ist mittlerweile Greyzone.
Also da haben dann weder die Russen noch die Ukrainer eine Stellung,
weil sie halt jetzt von den Ukrainern oben nicht wirklich zu halten waren.
Also du hast zwar diesen Vorteil, dass du oben auf dem Berg bist,
da kommst du jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres drauf, aber ist natürlich auch kein
besonders gut geschütztes Ziel.
Das heißt mit Artillerie man dort sehr viel Ärger erzeugen und das haben die
Russen natürlich mit Sicherheit getan, sodass es derzeit so aussieht,
als ob sich die Ukraine auf die Linie dahinter zurückgezogen hat.
Aber insgesamt sind diese Geländegewinne, die die Russen derzeit dort gemacht
haben, nicht besonders groß.
BG'IN TROZINSKI Ja und wie du schon gesagt hattest,
so dieser Hügel, dieser künstliche,
der ist zwischen 30 und 50 Metern über der russischen Seite und zwischen 10
und 20 Metern über der ukrainischen Seite,
sodass die Russen da auch einfach bergauf das Ding versorgen müssen und es ist
von russischer Seite auch schwerer zu halten als von ukrainischer.
Und dahinter ist dann eben eine Bahnlinie und dahinter ist halt dieses Industriegebiet
dieser vorigen jemaligen Kohleförderung.
Und das kennen wir ja schon auch aus Bachmuth und aus Mariupol.
Diese industriellen Orte sind natürlich,
massiven Gebäuden ausgestattet. Da ist also sehr viel Schutz.
Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein kleines Dorf, was mal eben mit Artillerie
dem Erdboden so ohne weiteres gleich gemacht werden kann.
Also bis wirklich Avdivka eingenommen
werden kann, das erfordert nochmal einen viel größeren Aufwand.
Und wenn man sich anschaut, wie viel Verluste sie jetzt schon hatten,
nur um diesen einen Erdhügel irgendwie mal von Ukrainern freizuräumen,
kann man sich in etwa vorstellen, was das dann noch nach sich ziehen würde.
Aber das ist ja eigentlich gar nicht ihre primäre Taktik, dort Avdivka direkt
anzugreifen, sondern eben diesen Ort einzuschließen.
Und dazu gibt es dann eben auch noch einen Vorstoß im Süden,
da sind die Geländegewinne einerseits auch sehr überschaubar.
Also das geht da schon seit langem so,
dass also die Russen da bestenfalls ein Gebiet von, naja, was ist das,
ungefähr ein Kilometer vielleicht, ein, zwei Kilometer haben vorstoßen können,
auf freiem Feld muss man dazu sagen.
Und das ist dann so halbe Strecke bis zu dem ersten Ort und dann werden die
Karten auch schon wieder ganz anders gemischt.
Und dazu kommt, dass in der Westflanke dieses Angriffs die Ukrainer wiederum
auch versuchen mit Gegenoffensiven dann auch noch diesen Versuch,
die Ukrainer abzuschneiden.
Versuchen dann die Ukrainer wiederum diesen Vorstoß abzuschneiden.
Also das ist militärisch noch lange nicht ausgewürfelt und meine Vermutung ist,
auch wenn das noch eine Weile ein Hauptschauplatz der Aktivitäten sein wird,
werden die Russen hier keinen großen Erfolg feiern können am Ende.
Also es erinnert mich so ein bisschen auch an die Vorstöße da bei Wuledar vor ein paar Monaten,
da sind die halt auch immer mit größeren Truppenkonzentrationen einfach ins
offene Messer gelaufen und haben einfach Verluste gehabt von irgendwie 100 Fahrzeugen
am Tag und so ähnlich läuft das halt jetzt hier auch gerade und ich frage mich,
wenn ich mir das auch immer wieder anschaue, wie viele Karren können die Russen eigentlich noch hier,
reinwerfen in diesen Konflikt. Also das ist wirklich crazy. BK'IN DR.
MERKEL Ja, ich meine, die haben teilweise jetzt ja wohl auch LKW,
die vor dem zweiten Weltkrieg gebaut wurden, so Baujahr 1925 oder so.
Jetzt wurden auch an der Front gesichtet, die schon seit 40 Jahren eigentlich
ausgemustert sind in der russischen Armee und die die im Zweiten Weltkrieg schon alt waren,
die sind jetzt an der Front aufgetaucht, also keine Ahnung, ob die da jetzt
ein Museum geplündert haben oder wie die an diese Dinger herangekommen sind.
Aber ja, auf der anderen Seite ist schon die russische Produktion auch durchaus angelaufen,
also man kann schon davon ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich so jeden Monat auch
100 neue oder reparierte Panzer an den Start kommen und mehrere hundert Panzerfahrzeuge.
Also das ist schon so, aber derzeit wird ungefähr wahrscheinlich dreimal so
viel zerstört an der Front, wie Russland nachbauen kann. Das ist so.
Zumindest, ja, also die Einschätzung, die ich am für realistischsten halte.
Wirklich genaue, belastbare Zahlen gibt es nicht, aber es gibt viele Hinweise,
dass das irgendwie realistisch sein könnte.
Und eher, ja, also nicht zu optimistisch für die russische Seite,
aber in der Gegend, was die Russen selber behaupten, dass sie in der Lage sind
zu produzieren mit ein bisschen Abstrichen.
So kommen die Zahlen zustande.
Sie haben sich jetzt auch nochmal kräftig bedient offenbar in Nordkorea.
Da laufen ja die Verhandlungen schon seit einigen Monaten und jetzt gibt es
also Berichte, dass da sowas in der Größenordnung von 1000 Containern mit Artilleriemunitionen
Nordkorea in Richtung Russland verlassen haben bzw.
Auf dem Weg sind in irgendeiner Form.
Vielleicht noch nicht vollständig, aber das ist so das, was die Gerüchteküche
gesagt hat, dass es in etwa diesen Umfang haben wird. Und da passt eine ganze
Menge rein. Also das sind dann schon so ein paar Millionen, die da an einzelnen
Granaten wieder an die Frontlinie geschickt werden können.
In welchem Zustand die sind, wie gut die sind, wie gut die funktionieren,
darüber weiß man wahrscheinlich noch sehr wenig.
Aber es ist offensichtlich, dass natürlich auch Russland alles dafür tut,
seine Munitionsbestände und natürlich auch seine sonstigen Kampfeinheiten in
irgendeiner Form wieder aufzustocken, inwiefern ihnen das gelingt, das wird man sehen.
Wenn sie allerdings so einen Verschleiß haben, wie jetzt gerade in Avdivka,
dann können sie irgendwie so viel produzieren, wie sie wollen.
Also da gehen die Bestände definitiv langsam zur Neige.
Und das gilt ja nicht nur für Panzer und andere gepanzerte Fahrzeuge direkt
aus der Militärproduktion, sondern eben auch vor allem für Logistikfahrzeuge.
Also Lastwagen, der Bedarf ist da sehr groß und teilweise bedienen sie sich
halt hier wiederum auch bei der Wirtschaft und ziehen halt ganz normale Lastwagen
ab, die dann auch wiederum nicht besonders gut geschützt sind etc.
Die Geschichten gibt es ja auch schon seit längerem, nur bisher hat es eben
noch nicht dazu geführt, dass dieser ganze Apparat zusammengebrochen ist.
Aber wie schon oft erwähnt, das funktioniert halt alles so lange,
bis es dann auf einmal von heute auf morgen komplett aufhört zu funktionieren
und dann wenden sich die Blätter.
Also hatten wir auch immer gesagt, also komplett ausgehen wird den Russen die Munition sobald nicht.
Und jetzt mit Korea, also Korea hat, Nordkorea hat nennenswerte Bestände,
vermutlich zig Millionen an Artillerie, Granaten.
Die für den Krieg gegen Südkorea in den letzten Jahrzehnten produziert wurden
oder teilweise auch gekauft wurden. Also ist keine gute Nachricht.
Ich würde das jetzt nicht einfach nur weglachen, so haha Nordkorea und so.
Auch wenn es Berichte gab, dass als die Nordkoreaner mal vor ich glaube 20 Jahren
zuletzt sich mal ein Artillerie-Gefecht geliefert hatten, eine Insel beschossen haben, dass dann
20 oder 30 Prozent der Munition nicht funktioniert haben, entweder nicht genug
Explosivkraft hatten und vorher ins Wasser gefallen sind oder überhaupt nicht gezündet sind.
Aber ob man das verallgemeinern kann, zumindest die Fotos von der Munition,
die ich gesehen die ja da aus Nordkorea kommt, die sah recht gut aus.
Also kein Vergleich mit dem, was man teilweise aus russischen Lagern gesehen
hat. Also schlimmer als das, auf was die Russen an alter Munition zurückgreifen,
kann das von den Nordkoreanern auch nicht sein.
Das wäre so mein Gefühl. Das ist tendenziell schon eher eine Verbesserung und
nicht gut für die Ukraine.
Genau, also man wird sehen wie sich das jetzt entwickelt. Zuletzt war es so,
dass eben nach Zählungen, also es gibt ja so Beobachter, die auch wirklich anhand von,
tja weiß ich nicht wie die das genau erfassen, von Lautstärkeaufzeichnungen oder so quasi messen,
wie viel Explosionen es gibt an welchen Stellen der Front und darauf Rückschlüsse
machen mit wie viel Artillerie denn jetzt hier tatsächlich verballert wird.
Und da war es also in den letzten zwei Monaten das Pendel ganz klar Richtung Ukraine umgeschwenkt.
Also die Russen haben in zunehmendem Maße weniger Artillerie,
Munition zum Einsatz gebracht. Ob das jetzt daran lag, dass sie keine haben
oder dass es daran lag, dass sie die nicht an die Front bekommen haben.
Das ist nochmal eine Frage für sich.
Aber das wird jetzt auch interessant sein zu sehen, wie sich das dann im Winter,
wenn ohnehin weniger Offensivaktivität zu erwarten ist, dann auffüllen wird.
Gut, gehen wir weiter zu einem weiteren Ort, wo sich ein bisschen was tut,
nämlich abgesehen von dieser Ostfront und der Südfront gibt es ja auch noch
die, naja, Südwestfront könnte man sagen.
Also Kherson, sprich die Grenze, die hier zwischen den Fronten definiert wird
durch den Verlauf des Libro.
Und ja, wir erinnern uns, dort ist ja der Staudamm gesprengt worden.
Dann gab es für einige Wochen starke
Überschwemmungen. Das ist natürlich mittlerweile alles Vergangenheit.
Das heißt, es hat sich jetzt im Prinzip wieder die normale Inselstruktur,
so wie man sie jetzt derzeit auf Google Earth und Google Maps noch beobachten
kann, wiederhergestellt.
Und ja, es gibt definitiv mehrere Aktivitäten der Ukrainer hier in irgendeiner Form überzusetzen.
Also es geht schon seit einiger Weile so, dass es immer wieder mit Speedbooten
einzelne Übertritte gibt von solchen Angriffsgruppen, kleinere Gruppen von,
keine Ahnung, 10, 20 Leuten vielleicht, die hier und da so ein paar Nadelstich durchgeführt haben.
Dann gab es ja den Vorstoß an den Überresten der Antonowsky-Brücke,
diese große Brücke, die beim Rückzug der Russen dann aus Resson komplett gesprengt wurde.
Dort haben sie sich dann quasi unter dieser Brücke auf der Südseite des Flusses,
haben sich die Ukrainer ein wenig eingegraben.
Aber mittlerweile gibt es eben zwei, drei, vier andere Stellen und auch Vorstöße
in diese ersten Dörfer nach den Flussinseln.
Wo es wohl den Ukrainern gelungen ist, nennenswert Alarm zu machen.
Man muss sich das jetzt nicht so vorstellen wie eine neue Offensive im eigentlichen
Sinne, denn derzeit ist es halt noch viel zu gefährlich für die Ukrainer.
Ein größeres Gerät dort rüber zu bringen. Weil man kann ja jetzt einfach mal
ein Panzer auf ein Boot setzen, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass der halt von der
russischen Artillerie weggeballert wird, ist halt relativ hoch.
Abgesehen davon hilft dir jetzt so ein Panzer auf der anderen Seite alleine
auch nichts. Du musst ja den auch versorgen können mit Sprit.
Du musst auch die Truppen versorgen können. Man muss in irgendeiner Form reparieren.
Also du brauchst sozusagen die kompletten Logistik Tross, wenn du eben wirklich
nennenswert in irgendeiner Form mechanisiert dort Angriffe durchführen willst.
Nichtsdestotrotz, die Russen sind halt generell in diesem Bereich auch nicht
besonders gut ausgestattet mit Personal. Personal. Einerseits,
weil sie sehr viel Richtung Togmark, also an den Vorstoß der Ukrainer,
den Hauptvorstoß der Ukrainer an der Südfront geschickt haben.
Und weil das auch so ein Gebiet ist, was so ein bisschen diffus ist,
also was sehr dünn besiedelt ist.
Dann gibt es eben Wüstengebiete, dann gibt es eben diese Flussgebiete des Dnipro,
alles sehr steppig, dazwischen sehr viel Landwirtschaft, also keine größeren
Ortschaften, keine besonders auffällig großen Ortschaften.
Es ist durchaus vorstellbar, dass der Ukraine hier noch mehr Vorstöße gelingen
können, die die Russen zumindest auf Trab halten.
Und natürlich immer die Vermutung, dass sie unter Umständen dann doch nochmal
irgendwas ganz pfiffiges planen,
weil es kann ja sein, dass sie mittlerweile im Bereich Boot oder so oder Flussüberquerung
sich irgendwas haben einfallen lassen, was sie dann irgendwann zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt ausrollen.
Das ganze wird ja auch dadurch gestützt, dass eben die Nordseite höher liegt.
Das heißt die Ukrainer haben den Vorteil, dass sie mit ihrer Artillerie quasi
bequem auf der anderen Seite des Flusses oben mit gutem Überblick und entsprechend
höheren Reichweiten diese Südfront dort abdecken können.
Können, während die Russen zwar auch immer wieder mit irgendwelchen Missiles
und Artilleriegeschützen dort für Ärger sorgen, aber halt militärisch nichts
wirklich nennenswert voranbringen können.
Das sieht dann natürlich auf der Südseite ganz anders aus. Also das muss man
mal abwarten, was sich hier entwickelt.
Ist auf jeden Fall auch spannend, weil alles was die Russen in irgendeiner Form
beschäftigt und sie müssen den Durchbruch eben überall fürchten,
kann einfach hier zu Fortschritten führen.
Also ich...
Ich sehe es so, dass, wie du richtig gesagt hast, die ukrainische Artillerie
reicht halt weit auch über den Fluss und wenn die jetzt Artilleriebeobachter,
die Ziele durchgeben können, dort auf der anderen Seite haben,
dann brauchen sie erstmal auch keine schweren Waffen in dem Bereich,
wo die Artillerie reicht, weil sie dann eben aus der Ferne Artillerie anfordern.
Können. Sodass ich damit rechne eigentlich,
dass sie sich da auf dem Streifen auf jeden Fall erst mal festsetzen können,
so weil sie Artillerieunterstützung von hinten haben und ja auch ganz gut ausgestattete
Truppen mit Nachtsichtgeräten und allem.
Insofern ja ist das Das ist meine Erwartung und allzu weit vorrücken können
sie aber jetzt auch nicht,
wobei angeblich es größere Vorstöße gegeben hat,
aber die Russen haben halt auch Artillerie und je weiter sie jetzt sich von
ihrer eigenen Artillerie entfernen,
umso gefährlicher wird es wiederum für die Ukrainer,
sodass sich da, ich vermute, so eine Art Gleichgewicht einpendeln wird,
wo die Ukrainer erst mal dort am Ufer bleiben und natürlich versuchen werden,
so viel Ärger zu machen, wie es geht, um die Russen zu zwingen,
von anderswo Truppen abzuziehen.
Das ist, denke ich, im Moment das, was die Ukrainer dort gerade machen,
weil so eine Komplette amphibische Operationen sehe ich noch nicht,
aber ausschließend kann man sie aus Sicht der Russen natürlich auch nicht völlig,
aber das unbemerkt zu machen, schwierig.
Genau, also an einem dieser Vorstoßpunkte, den sie jetzt zuletzt eingenommen
haben bei Krynki, wo es also Berichte und wenn wir jetzt von Berichten sprechen,
reden wir tatsächlich primär von russischen Berichten.
Also von ukrainischer Seite wird relativ wenig davon erzählt,
sondern das sind dann immer diese russischen Militärblogger,
die diese Storys aufpoppen lassen und man kann immer davon ausgehen,
dass wenn die irgendwie berichten, oh hier krasser Vorstoß und wir haben große
Verluste und so weiter, dass da auch ein Fünkchen Wahrheit da dran ist,
weil es jetzt sagen wir mal nicht so in der Tendenz liegt.
Der Russen zuzugeben, dass sie in irgendeiner Form verloren haben.
Also zumindest das Government nicht.
Und gerade dieser Brückenkopf, wenn es denn einer ist da in Krinki,
hätte so ein bisschen das Potenzial auch so eine der wichtigen Ost-West-Verbindungsstraßen
zu bedrohen. bedrohen. Also das ist schon auch so ein strategisch ganz interessanter
Ort, den sie dort besetzt haben.
Definitiv wird das den Russen nochmal eine ganze Menge Ärger bereiten.
Aber das ist alles ein, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, Nebenkriegsschauplatz.
Da gehen Sachen ab und das ist etwas, was man im Blick behalten muss.
Und ich rechne immer mit irgendwelchen pfiffigen Vorstößen, aber derzeit ist das alles noch offen.
Schauen wir jetzt mal aber auf die große Nachricht der letzten zwei Wochen.
Wir haben ja schon länger und immer wieder mal darüber gesprochen,
welche Waffensysteme denn die Amerikaner und auch andere Länder den Ukrainern
gegebenenfalls noch zur Verfügung stellen könnten.
Die Wunschliste der Ukrainer war ja lang und ziemlich weit oben auf dieser Wunschliste
waren die sogenannten Attackams-Raketen.
Diese scheinen nun nicht nur in die Ukraine gekommen zu sein endlich,
sondern sie wurden dann auch schon zum Einsatz gebracht und das auf eine recht
effektive Art und Weise.
Ja also sie haben spektakulären Erstauftritt spektakuläres Debüt gemacht auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe ja vorhin schon erwähnt, eines der Hauptprobleme der ukrainischen Offensive
im Süden war, abgesehen von den Minenfeldern, dass die Russen immer in der Lage
waren mit Kampfhubschraubern zu antworten.
Und die können halt aus einer relativ großen Weite sehr gezielt Raketen auf
die Angriffstrupps abschicken und haben das auch getan,
ohne dass die halt in die Reichweite von der Luftverteidigung oder Drohnen oder
irgendwelchen Manpads oder sowas gekommen sind, weil die einfach nicht nah genug dran sind.
Und das war schon auch echt ein richtig großes Problem. Also die Hubschrauber
waren so ein großes Problem.
Und tatsächlich haben die Russen aber diese Hubschrauber von ziemlich weit her heranfliegen lassen.
Es gibt da einen größeren Standort einerseits in Berdyansk, der ist ungefähr
so 98 Kilometer von der Frontlinie entfernt, 100 Kilometer von der Frontlinie entfernt.
Und wir wissen, dass diese High-Mars-Systeme ungefähr so einen 80 Kilometer
Range haben. Also sie waren sozusagen out of reach für High-Mars-Systeme.
Es gab einen entsprechenden anderen Militär-Hubschrauber-Standort bei Luhansk, in der Stadt Luhansk.
Und auch dort war der Abstand entsprechend.
Also die Russen haben sozusagen ihre Hubschrauber versteckt und zwar an einem
Ort, der also so deutlich über 80 Kilometer entfernt war.
Nun sind aber diese Atacams-Raketen verfügbar geworden.
Und wir wissen, dass es Attack-Ims waren, weil es halt mittlerweile auch zugegeben
wurde und es auch offensichtlich war, weil die Überreste gefunden wurden.
Ja, dann sollten wir vielleicht erstmal erzählen, worum es sich dabei handelt.
Die Attack-Ims Raketen sind Raketen, die darauf optimiert sind,
also taktische Raketen, die darauf optimiert sind, spezielle Ziele anzufliegen,
die relativ präzise fliegen, auch wenn sie tatsächlich in der Form,
wie die Ukraine sie bekommen hat, jetzt nicht mit GPS-Navigation ausgestattet sind.
Aber trotzdem relativ akkurat die Ziele anfliegen können und die vor allem ziemlich
groß sind und sehr viel Explosionsmaterial haben.
Konkret sieht es so aus, dass sie die erste Generation dieser Attack-M's Raketen erhalten haben.
So genannten, ja jetzt gibt es viele Bezeichnungen, die man jetzt hier wählen
kann. Also generell fällt das Ganze unter MG M140 Attack-M's und die Variante,
die hier gewählt wurde es der sogenannte Typ M39 oder auch Block 1.
Und haben die jetzt GPS oder nicht? Nein. Kein GPS. Und sie sind aber gefüllt
mit vielen kleinen Einzelmunitionen.
Also es ist im Prinzip eine Clusterbomben Rakete, die kurz vor dem Ziel sich sozusagen absprengt,
den Kopf und durch eine Rotation dann alle diese kleinen,
ich weiß nicht, Kokosnuss großen Bomblets breit verteilt über einen Raum von,
weiß nicht, 200 Meter oder so, sodass die dann eben einzeln aufschlagen,
dann explodieren und dann entsprechend natürlich auch noch mit ihren einzelnen
Teilen, mit ihrem Schrapnell noch sehr viel mehr Ärger anstellen.
Und Wenn also 950 sozusagen einzelne Bomben in einem Bereich von 200 mal 200
Meter aufschlagen, dann ist richtig Alarm.
Insbesondere wenn es sich um, wie es so schön heißt, weiche Ziele handelt.
Also entweder um Personal oder eben auch.
Fluggerät. Und damit sind sie also nun auf diese Hubschrauberlandeplätze oder
diese Hubschrauberstationen angeflogen und haben die wohl auch ziemlich präzise getroffen.
In Berdyansk sind drei Attackams angeschlagen und in Luhansk zwei.
Der Berdyansk Airport ist auch größer und man hat dann relativ schnell auf den
Satellitenbildern, die danach veröffentlicht wurden, gesehen,
dass die Zerstörung umfangreich war.
Also sie haben sehr gut getroffen, die haben sozusagen diesen gesamten Bereich
abgedeckt und man konnte relativ schnell am Anfang schon ausmachen,
dass also viele Hubschrauber dort komplett zerstört worden sind.
Andere davon offenbar auch so stark beschossen wurden, dass sie nicht mehr flugtauglich sind.
Ich glaube, der letzte Stand war, dass ungefähr bei
diesen Angriffen mit fünf Attack-Imps-Raketen irgendwas in der Größenordnung
von 21 Hubschraubern und sonstigen Flugzeugen auch noch und auch noch ein paar
Luftabwehrsystemen und auch noch Munitionsdepots komplett zerstört wurden.
Ja und vermutlich auch so Wartungsgeräte,
die da rumstanden, was weiß ich, Generatoren, Stromversorgungen und anderes
Ground Equipment, sag ich mal, was speziell für die Wartung dieser Fluggeräte zuständig ist.
Dass es auch nicht so einfach von der Stange zu kaufen gibt.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall krass. Diese Attack-Hymns haben ja auch eine deutlich
größere Reichweite. Das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt. Die können halt bis
zu 165 Kilometer weit fliegen und damit ist natürlich jetzt alles auf einmal
in Range, was vorher nicht in Range war.
Ja, also vielleicht auch noch zum Hintergrund,
man könnte jetzt erstmal auch sagen, okay, die Amerikaner haben jetzt die allerältesten Tech-Homes,
die sie noch nicht verschrottet haben, jetzt in die Ukraine geliefert,
weil die Dinger sind schon länger ausgemustert und zur Verschrottung vorgesehen so.
Also die US-Armee hat diesen Typ seit 20 Jahren nicht mehr eingesetzt oder zumindest
schon lange ausgemustert.
Und ja, wie schon gesagt, das sind ganz schöne Brocken und es wurde dann kritisiert, oh Gott, wieso?
Alte Kram und auch nur mit 160 km Reichweite, weil ja die neueren dann auch
bis 300 km Reichweite kommen.
Aber der Vorteil tatsächlich von diesen alten Dingern ist,
dass sie ja 950 Stück an Submunition haben, während die 300.
Kilometer Reichweite eine deutlich niedrigere Nutzlast hat und dann auch nur
mit 300 von diesen Bomblets daher kommt.
Das heißt eigentlich für diesen Zweck,
für den sie jetzt eingesetzt wurden, waren die ältesten Waffen tatsächlich die geeignetsten,
weil auch die 300 Kilometer Reichweite bezahlst du einfach mit sehr viel Sprit
und eben sehr viel weniger Nutzlast.
Und wozu das nehmen, wenn das Ziel in 100 Kilometer Entfernung liegt?
Also insofern wird davon auch ausgegangen,
dass sie auch Zugriff auf neuere Attackums haben,
grundsätzlich die Ukraine, aber dass das einfach auch jetzt für den Zweck die
richtige Waffe war und die moderneren Dinger,
die entweder dann weniger Bomblitz haben oder eher auch nur einen einen großen
Fragmentierungssprengkopf wären, gegen dieses Ziel längst nicht so wirksam gewesen.
A. Also selbst wenn sie alle Atacams-Modelle zur Verfügung gehabt hätten,
hätten sie dafür genau die genommen? B.
Genau. Das ist genau der Punkt.
Und zur Genauigkeit ist es so,
dass laut Source Intelligence Angaben die 250 Meter Circular Error Probability oder CEP haben,
Das heißt, die Hälfte der abgeschossenen Raketen landet in einem Kreis mit dem
Durchmesser von 250 Metern Durchmesser.
Das gilt für diese Nicht-GPS-Typen.
Die selbe Variante dann, die es auch mit GPS gibt,
schafft aber auch nur 150 Meter CEP Und erst die ganz neuen schaffen halt 10
Meter, die dann gegen Bunker und ähnliches eingesetzt werden.
Und ich gehe davon aus, auch weil ja jetzt Atacams durch Prism ersetzt wird,
die neuere Rakete, wo auch dann zwei davon in einen Launcher passen,
von den Atacams passt jetzt nur eine und die auch nochmal größere Reichweite
und so haben, da läuft wohl jetzt gerade die Produktion an.
Und man nimmt an, dass jetzt die Ukraine quasi alle alten Techems bekommen wird
in der Zahl, wie jetzt neue Prisms produziert werden.
Plus den alten Kram, der sowieso ausgemustert ist und alles in allem könnte
es sich dann um bis zu tausend von diesen Attackers handeln,
die noch da sind, sodass man ausgehen kann, dass wahrscheinlich auf jeden Fall
hunderte davon noch an die Ukraine gehen werden.
Also das ist eine Waffe,
die für die Ukraine sowohl strategischen Wert hat,
als auch für die USA sozusagen einen ökonomischen Wert hat, weil die zu entsorgen
hätte nur Geld gekostet, die
in die Ukraine zu fahren natürlich auch ein bisschen, aber nicht so viel.
Und von daher ist das sozusagen doppelter Nutzen und auch von der Wirkung her,
also ich meine wenn man das jetzt mal rein finanziell nachrechnet ist ein bisschen
skurrile Sichtweise, das gebe ich zu, aber auch diese Perspektive kann man ja mal aufmachen.
Also das was da quasi an militärischem Material bei den Russen zerstört wird
durch diese Raketen ist ein Vielfaches von dem was man ursprünglich mal für
diese Raketen finanziell aufgewendet hat.
Ja, also selbst wenn sie noch etwas wert wären, so was sie wie gesagt wahrscheinlich,
also verkaufen kann man die Dinger nicht mehr.
Nein, nein, aber du hast ja Geld dafür eingesetzt, das ist ja irgendwann mal ausgegeben worden.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, aber speziell bei denen ist es tatsächlich so,
dass die alle zur Verschottung vorgesehen sind und ja, es sind auch,
also die Dinger sehen ein bisschen teuflisch aus.
Hast gesagt, diese Submunition, so ungefähr Kokusnuss groß und hat auch so ein Profil,
so mit vier Kurven, die dafür sorgen, dass das dann, wenn es durch die Luft
fliegt, in Rotation versetzt wird.
Und um scharf gemacht zu werden, müssen, muss jedes von diesen Submunitionsdingern
sich mit mindestens 2.000 Umdrehungen pro Minute drehen, also auf 2.500,
Umdrehungen pro Minute kommen, damit die scharf gemacht werden. A.
Das heißt, wenn die einfach umkippen, dann explodieren die erstmal nicht so ohne Weiteres.
B. Ja, ja. Und selbst wenn die einfach auch nur einschlagen irgendwo,
dann explodieren die nicht, weil die nicht scharf gemacht sind.
Also jedenfalls nicht durch, ja die zünden dann nicht und also diese Cluster
Munition ist ja unter anderem so auch in der Kritik wegen ja Kontamination durch Submunition,
sprich nicht explodierte Submunition bleibt liegen und bei diesen Attackums
sind es so 20 von 950 Stück wohl, die nicht explodieren.
Aber von den 20, ich meine klar, die stellen zwar eine Gefahr da,
man kann dann auch wieder davon ausgehen, dass von den 20 wahrscheinlich ein
Großteil nicht explodieren, weil sie eben nicht diese notwendige Rotationsgeschwindigkeit
erreicht haben und nicht scharf gemacht wurden.
So, das ist halt die Situation. Und, wie wir auch in den letzten Rechten letztes Mal gesagt haben.
Dort, wo das jetzt eingesetzt wird,
ist entweder der Boden ohnehin so stark kontaminiert mit Submunition oder es
ist, wie in diesem Fall, ja dann erstmal ein Problem der Russen.
Und es ist halt ein militärisches Ziel. Insofern ist das jetzt auch kein Kriegsverbrechen
oder so, diese Dinger einzusetzen.
Und die Russen, muss man auch sagen, setzen Cluster-Munition seit Beginn des Krieges ein.
Aber trotzdem sieht das wirklich sehr, sehr teuflisch aus. Und wie du eben auch
schon gesagt hast, wirken vor allem gegen Personen ungepanzerte Fahrzeuge,
besonders Luftfahrzeuge.
Was noch zu erwähnen ist, es gibt eben auch brandstiftendes Material,
also diese Hülle, wenn das Ding fragmentiert,
werden auch Fragmente, die ja Dinge in Brand setzen,
mit verschleudert, sodass wir, weshalb wir dann eben auch brennende Hubschrauber
gesehen haben oder wenn da irgendwelche Tankfahrzeuge sind oder so,
können die dann auch durch ein glühendes Schrapnell in Brand gesetzt werden und explodieren.
Also ja, das vielleicht zu den Attackums mit. A.
Sieht es ja auch so aus, also die sind ja, ich weiß nicht genau,
wie die Steuerung dieser Raketen funktioniert, wenn sie keinen GPS haben,
aber trotzdem halbwegs akkurat sind? B.
Naja, die haben ein Trägheitsnavigationssystem, einfach drei Kreisel,
drei kleine Kreisel Vorher wird ihnen gesagt, wo sie sich befinden vor dem Abschuss
und ja, dann machen sie das mit Trägheitsnavigation.
A.
Aber die haben dann keine ballistische Kurve, sondern die können schon auch
einen spezifischen Pfad fliegen. B.
Die können auch, das war das andere Ding, was ich halt wissen wollte,
weil es war halt die Debatte, wie einfach sind denn die Dinger eigentlich abzuschießen und,
Die können auch auf jeden Fall, das habe ich gefunden an Information, Trajectory Shaping.
Also die haben aktive Elektronik, die halt ins Ziel steuert und auch dann ausgleicht
Wind und andere Dinge, aber man kann wohl da auch verschiedene Flugbahnoptionen einstellen.
Und dann ist es auch so, dass sie nicht notwendigerweise genau aufs Ziel ausgerichtet sein müssen.
Das heißt, du kannst allein schon mal über die Richtung, in der du sie abschießt zum Beispiel,
du kannst sie dann halt seitlich so mit ein paar Grad Abweichung nicht direkt
auf das Ziel abschießen, sodass sie dann quasi eine Kurve von außen drehen.
Oder du kannst auch wohl Profile einstellen, wo
sie dann entweder eine höhere oder eine tiefere kurve
fliegen so oder erst mal in eine bestimmte richtung
und dann abbiegen sozusagen um irgendwas spezifisch zum
fliegen also das habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden ob
du auch waypoints ein programmieren kannst so dass da bin ich mir nicht sicher
also dass das wäre möglich aber so So bei dem Block 1 würde ich das mal eher nicht vermuten,
aber du hast halt genug andere Möglichkeiten, die Flugbahn zu variieren von denen.
Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass sie jetzt bei diesen Angriffen ungefähr 120
Kilometer geflogen sind von diesen 165, die sie maximal fliegen können.
Da wird jetzt der Umweg sicherlich nicht zu groß gewesen sein,
aber dadurch, dass eben GPS-Jamming nicht hinhaut und es auch keine ballistische Kurve ist,
Funktionieren halt die typischen von den Russen eingesetzten Abwehrsysteme nicht
so gut und offensichtlich scheint eben auch die ganze Luftabwehr noch nicht
unbedingt so sehr darauf vorbereitet gewesen zu sein.
Auf jeden Fall sind jetzt diese beiden Landeplätze für Hubschrauber,
ja, ziemlich im Eimer und die Hubschrauber dazu und es gibt auch schon erste
Meldungen, dass die Zahl der Angriffe mit Hubschraubern an der Südfront,
Surprise, Surprise, in den letzten Tagen stark nachgelassen hat.
Das bedeutet, dass ja eigentlich alles außer der Südkrim ist jetzt in Reichweite von Atacams,
so das bedeutet also der gesamte restliche Teil von Resson im Westen,
der gesamte restliche besetzte Teil von Saporishia im Süden,
aber auch das vollständige Gebiet in Luhansk und das vollständige Gebiet in,
Was habe ich vergessen? Im Donbass, also in Donetsk ist sozusagen jetzt erreichbar.
Das heißt in dem Moment, wo es in irgendeiner Form nennenswerte Truppen oder
Materialkonzentrationen gibt oder Hauptquartiere bekannt sind,
die in irgendeiner Form mit den jetzt verfügbaren Attack-Missiles sinnvoll angegriffen
werden können, wird die Ukraine das machen.
Beziehungsweise die Russen wissen das natürlich auch und werden sich halt entsprechend
dann, tja, wohin denn eigentlich zurückziehen.
Also gerade in Saporischia, Berdiansk ist quasi der südlichste Punkt der Front,
also der besetzten Gebiete.
Es gibt da jetzt keinen Ort, wo sie noch weiter wegziehen können.
Wenn man jetzt quasi diesen 165 oder sagen wir mal 140 Kilometer Kreis in diesem Gebiet aufzieht,
immer jeweils von der Front, da gibt es jetzt gar nicht so viele Orte,
wo die Russen überhaupt noch irgendwie Hubschrauber stationieren können.
Und das ist natürlich für die ein echtes Problem.
Die müssen im Prinzip die Hubschrauber in Russland stationieren,
wenn sie in irgendeiner Form noch unerreichbar sein wollen, jetzt für diese neuen Waffensysteme.
Und das ist für die natürlich ein riesiges Problem, weil selbst wenn sie das
tun, also wenn jetzt, sagen wir mal, die Hubschrauber 150,
160 Kilometer hinter der Frontlinie irgendwo platziert werden,
Jetzt muss erstmal die Logistik dafür wieder neu aufgebaut werden.
Okay, das können sie irgendwie noch hinbekommen.
Aber das würde ja dann auch bedeuten, dass jedes Mal, wenn die in Angriff fliegen
müssen, die einfach auch nochmal sehr viel längeren Flug haben und das ihre
Einsatzzeit natürlich auch begrenzt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie diese KA, wie heißen die KA-9 Hubschrauber,
was die überhaupt für eine Reichweite haben.
Aber irgendwann sind die ja dann auch nicht mehr in der Lage an der Front einzugreifen.
BK'IN DR.
MERKEL – Ja, also es verlängert tatsächlich einfach die Anfahrtzeit zur Front
und dementsprechend verkürzt die Läutertime,
die sie haben und du brauchst dann praktisch mehr Hubschrauber,
um denselben Effekt zu erreichen und insofern haben diese Angriffe jetzt auch
schon mal Strategisch einfach dazu geführt,
so dass die gesamte russische Luftwaffe noch ineffektiver geworden ist dadurch,
selbst wenn jetzt keine weiteren Hubschrauber mehr zerstört werden.
Wobei dann ja die russische Luftwaffe ja auch noch den Ukrainern den Gefallen
getan hat, zwei eigene Hubschrauber abzuschießen. Ich weiß nicht,
ob du das mitbekommen hast.
A. Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu. B.
Ja, bei verschiedenen Dingen. Das heißt,
als russischer Hubschrauberpilot musst du dich jetzt auch noch,
ja, oder vermutlich schon immer genauso vor der eigenen Luftabwehr fürchten,
Flugabwehr, wie vor der gegnerischen.
Und da ging jetzt dann der Witz um. Also die Piloten vom Hubschrauber haben
halt sofort jetzt ihre Tapferkeitsmedaillen bekommen.
Und in ein paar Wochen kriegen dann auch die Besatzung der russischen Luftabwehr,
die das abgeschossen hat, dann ihre Medaillen.
Nur nicht zum selben Zeitpunkt wäre gerade vielleicht ein bisschen.
Aber so scheinen die Russen auch zu ticken. Wobei es natürlich auch die Amerikaner
hatten in sämtlichen Konflikten.
Sogar mehr Verluste durch Blue on Blue vorkommen, friendly fire,
als durch gegnerische Einwirkung.
Im Golfkrieg wurden mehr amerikanische Soldaten von eigenen Truppen umgebracht
als von irakischen Soldaten.
Und insofern ist das jetzt nicht ungewöhnlich, aber es ist natürlich trotzdem,
ich sag mal jetzt zwei Hubschrauber innerhalb von einer Woche.
Das ist ungewöhnlich, das ist, ja.
TROZINSKI Ja, also man kann davon ausgehen, dass jetzt dieser gesamte Angriff
mit Attack Imps doch die ganze Hubschrauberflotte erheblich dezimiert hat.
Dazu kommt ja auch noch, dass dann hubschrauberspezifische Munition auch mit
zerstört wurde. Wie viel das ausmacht und wie viel dort noch lagert und verfügbar
ist, das weiß glaube ich keiner so ganz genau.
Aber das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall ein interessanter Trend. Sprich mit Attack
Imps hat die Ukraine eine erhebliche Waffe erhalten.
In Mengen, die wenn man, jetzt sagen wir mal auf dem Papier nicht groß ist, 20.
Aber wenn man sich anschaut, was sie mit 5 schon ausgerichtet haben und wenn
sie jetzt auch noch die anderen 15 sinnvoll zum Einsatz bringen,
dann ist das für die signifikant.
Also das ist etwas, was man sich auch schon früher gewünscht hätte,
wäre zum Beispiel jetzt Attack-Ims schon im letzten Frühjahr verfügbar gewesen,
ein halbes Jahr vorher und man hätte quasi vor dieser Offensive im Süden mit
den Attack-Ims diese Shaping-Operation machen können,
also hier die Hubschrauberstandorte platt machen, dann hätte das vielleicht
jetzt nicht alles geändert, aber das wäre definitiv etwas gewesen,
was dazu beigetragen hätte, entweder den Vorstoß,
weniger, also weniger Leben zu verlieren dabei oder eben auch in puncto Landgewinne
da schnellere Fortschritte zu erzielen.
Das ist halt das Bittere natürlich, was aber niemand oder die meisten Leute
jetzt nicht zu laut sagen wollen,
ist ja, dass die Tatsache, dass man Diese Waffen,
mit denen man sowieso nichts mehr anfangen konnte, die zur Verschrottung vorgesehen
waren, erst jetzt geliefert hat, hat wahrscheinlich ukrainische Soldaten das Leben gekostet.
Das ist halt so. Aber dann sagt man sich natürlich wiederum als Ukraine,
okay, lieber spät als nie, aber nichtsdestotrotz hat es natürlich immer so ein Geschmäckle.
Gerade in diesem,
Fall, also diese uralten M39 Dinger, also diesen alten Schrott hätte man auch
problemlos vor ein paar Monaten schon schicken können.
Aber so ist es nun mal, politisch dauern die Sachen dann einfach ein bisschen.
Wo wir noch bei Munitionen sind, also diese GLSDB, also diese Gliding Bombs,
die sind offensichtlich noch nicht gesehen worden, sollen aber jetzt,
also schon seit längerem, jeden Moment verfügbar sein.
Die Russen setzen so eine Munition auch ein und das wohl auch relativ erfolgreich.
Also man kann hier nur hoffen, dass auch das kommt, weil dann ist eben zielgenaues
Treffen auch noch auf längere Strecken möglich und dann wird es logistisch für
die Russen noch mal richtig anstrengend.
Also generell vielleicht, weil wir in dem Punkt sind, sollte man noch ein paar
Worte vielleicht zu den Russen sagen oder generell,
Ja, wie sich die Russen denn jetzt auch in den letzten Monaten grundsätzlich
angepasst haben und was halt ja jetzt auch in Avdivka oder an anderen Fronten viel zum Einsatz kommt,
sind die Lancet-Drohnen, die, das ist so eine Loitering Munition, relativ modern.
Also Loitering Munition ist so ein selbstfliegendes oder ferngesteuertes Flugzeug,
was rumfliegt und so lange sucht, bis es irgendwas findet und dann angreift.
Ja und die Dinger, was halt auch bemerkenswert ist, ist, dass in den Dingern
so ein Jetson TX2 von Nvidia drin sitzt.
Also ich habe hier auch einen Entwicklerboard davon rumliegen.
Also ich kenne das Zeugs.
Und ja, dann haben sie da Xilinx FPGAs noch drin und so. Und die Dinger haben
auf jeden Fall nennenswert Elektronik.
Also im Teslas übrigens, es gab es auch den Jetson TX2, wurde auch genutzt.
Also so autonome Fahren, KI-Geschichten und Visual Computing ist der halt hervorragend
geeignet zu dieser Jetson TX2.
Und ja, das ist so die Waffe jetzt,
mit der sie am meisten ukrainische Artillerie bekämpfen, weil irgendwie kriegen
sie es mit ihrer eigenen Artillerie, kriegen sie das Counter Battery war ja nicht so hin.
Aber mit diesen Lancets, so haben sie jetzt einige schmerzliche Erfolge erzielt.
Und das war das eine. Und dann haben sie bis eben auf Divka auch vermieden größere
Truppenkonzentrationen in der Nähe der Front,
sich auch eben angepasst und Vorräte und Truppen weit verteilt,
was natürlich wieder für Disziplinprobleme sorgt, aber eben geholfen hat,
bis auf Divka so die Verluste in Grenzen zu halten, oder zumindest zu reduzieren.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz hat die Ukraine ja eine Drohnenübermacht,
wahrscheinlich von 3 zu oder 5 zu 1 an der Front.
Und offensichtlich muss man sagen, hatte Russland auch noch genug Material in
der Reserve, um das jetzt bei Avdivka zu verfeuern.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie jetzt überhaupt nichts mehr hatten und
sie sind durchaus auch zur Offensivoperation noch in der Lage.
Was man eben auch gesehen hat, ist, dass das Zusammenspiel dann nicht wirklich
gut funktioniert hat der verschiedenen Waffen,
also Combined Arms, weil da gab es viel Kritik von russischer Seite,
dass die angreifenden Truppen eben keine vernünftige Artillerieunterstützung
hatten und nur eben mithilfe von hier und da Länze drohen.
Aber davon gibt es halt auch zu wenig. Und insofern ist das die Situation jetzt der russischen Armee,
dass sie an vielen Stellen zwar eng und knapp mit allem sind,
aber jetzt auch nicht völlig inkompetent oder jetzt gerade vor dem Zusammenbruch
stehen, so würde würde ich das jetzt.
Mal interpretieren, wie die Situation ist.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch noch andere Gebiete, wo sie Probleme haben und auch
die haben wir schon angesprochen, die haben sich weiter verschärft,
nämlich im Schwarzen Meer.
Die Schwarzmeerflotte Russlands hat sich mittlerweile, kann man sagen,
komplett zurückgezogen,
weil es den Ukrainern gelungen ist,
mit ihrer Technik, also mit ihren Drohnenbooten, aber auch mit ihren Raketenangriffen
Speziell Stormshadow, wir hatten hier den Angriff auf das Trockendog in Sevastopol
schon vermeldet und diverse andere Schiffe auch.
Es gibt jetzt also eine Reihe von Satellitenbeobachtungen, die nachweisen,
dass also der Hafen in Sevastopol weitgehend verbarrikadiert ist.
Aber verlassen ist sozusagen von der Schwarzmeerflotte, also die großen Kampfschiffe,
die haben sich alle zurückgezogen und sind jetzt in den Hafen von Noworossijsk zurückgezogen worden.
Ja und das bedeutet im Prinzip, dass eben diese Beherrschung des Meeres,
die diese Flotte eigentlich ausüben soll und vor allem natürlich auch das Durchsetzen
dieses Getreidebockkotts so nicht mehr funktioniert.
Sprich, es ist zwar jetzt noch nicht in demselben Maße wie zu der Zeit,
als es dieses Abkommen gab für Getreidelieferungen, der Verkehr wieder aufgenommen
worden, aber das lässt sich halt in zunehmendem Maße an.
Und dazu kommt, dass eben auch noch diese ganzen Vereinbarungen getroffen worden sind.
Mit anderen Häfen. Das hatten wir glaube ich das letzte Mal angesprochen,
dass uns nicht ganz klar ist, wie sie das mit den Eisenbahnen dort machen übrigens.
Da gab es interessantes Feedback dazu. Also es gibt tatsächlich automatische
Umrüstungssysteme an den Grenzen, wo also die Züge auf der vollen Länge oder zumindest auf einer.
Ziemlich langen Länge, ich hatte das jetzt nur für Personenzüge gesehen,
wo er das alles nochmal sozusagen nacherzählt und schaut okay was ist als Game
Changer vorne rein gehandelt worden und was hat es dann letzten Endes auf dem
Schlachtfeld tatsächlich bewirkt und was hat das sozusagen gekostet.
Alles das nochmal aufzählt, ganz interessant nochmal so als Anmerkung.
Auf jeden Fall, Schwarzmeerflotte ist nicht da und das ist im Prinzip jetzt
die militärische Situation wie sie sich uns darstellt.
Ja, vielleicht einfach nochmal ganz kurz auf diesen Vorfall,
muss man sagen, eingehen, der sich in der Ostsee abgespielt hat.
Es gibt eine Gaspipeline zwischen Finnland und Estland.
Wir sind nicht ganz so sicher, in welche Richtung da Gas fließt.
Auf jeden Fall ist das eine wichtige Infrastruktur dieser beiden Länder.
Und dort gab es eine Unterbrechung nach Ereignis.
Und das machte erstmal wieder so diesen Eindruck so oh oh, ist jetzt hier wieder
was zur Explosion gebracht worden und wenn ja woran lag es?
Hast du da einen Einblick, was dort passiert ist oder angeblich passiert ist? BK'IN DR.
Ja, also die letzten Meldungen sprechen davon,
dass es ein Anker war, ein Schiffsanker, der über die Pipeline rübergezogen
wurde und die dann beschädigt hat und sich dann da verfangen hat.
Die Finnen haben ein Foto veröffentlicht von einem riesigen Schiffsanker,
von dem sie vermuten, dass er die Pipeline beschädigt hat.
Anfangs war ja auch von Explosionen die Rede, die erfasst wurden von irgendwelchen
Seismometern oder von irgendwelchen Mikrofonen.
Aber wenn du so eine große Pipeline plötzlich aufreißt, hast du immer eine gewaltige
Explosion bei Drücken von 100, 200 Bar, die wahrscheinlich in dieser Pipeline sind.
Und sie haben das Schiff zwar noch nicht ganz,
also mit 100%iger Sicherheit gerade,
identifiziert, sie gehen davon aus,
dass es ein chinesisches Containerschiff namens New New Polar Bear,
so, also dieses, das heißt wirklich New New Polar Bear oder New New Polar Bear,
keine Ahnung, wie dieser Name zustande gekommen ist,
aber ja, und versuchen jetzt gerade dieses Schiff irgendwie zu kontaktieren,
das meldet sich aber nicht, soll aber eben einen Anker wohl auch verloren haben. A.
Mh. Müssen Sie das nicht melden, sowas? B. Tja. Tja.
Also bei den Chinesen traue ich ja alles zu.
Ich meine, wie die sich weltweit mit ihren Schiffen gebärden,
nur ganz kurz, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitgekriegt hast.
Also was jetzt schon seit Jahrzehnten vor sich geht, ist,
dass sie alte Schiffswracks einfach stehlen, die eigentlich so,
wo die als Monumente, als Denkmäler geschützt sind, als Kriegsdenkmäler und so.
Aber der Stahl ist halt extrem viel wert und weil noch nicht durch nukleare Isotope verseucht,
kriegst du für diese alten Schiffe ein Premium und da haben sich schon Dutzende
alte Schiffswracks einfach zerstört.
Von den Fischerflotten, die überall einfahren und dann auch Raubbau betreiben, kurz erwähnt.
Ja, die Chinesen benehmen sich einfach nicht gut auf See oder im Ausland und
insofern halte ich das jetzt für plausibel.
Aber es könnte natürlich auch eine bequeme Cover-Story sein.
Aber ich halte es für plausibel und insbesondere die Details und so weiter.
Und ich denke, das wird sich jetzt in Kürze aufklären.
Und es waren nicht nur die Pipelines, sondern auch noch weitere Datenleitungen,
Telekommunikationsleitungen, die da entlang verlegt waren, sind auch beschädigt worden.
A. Ok, dann vielleicht nochmal zurück zur Kriegssituation.
Was denken wir denn jetzt, wie das weitergehen kann? Also was erwartet uns denn
jetzt im Herbst und im Frühjahr?
Tja, also ich erwarte aktuell jetzt erst mal keine größeren Überraschungen oder
größeren Wänden im Kampfgeschehen so.
Es sieht nicht so aus, als wenn einer Seite jetzt gerade die Luft ausgeht oder
eine Seite vor irgendwelchen spektakulären Durchbrüchen steht.
Steht, aber wie du auch richtig gesagt hast, Situationen sind so lange stabil,
bis sie dann plötzlich nicht mehr stabil sind.
Aber ich sehe jetzt gerade auch erstmal keine Indikatoren oder Anzeichen,
wie auch in den letzten Monaten.
Die dafür sprechen, dass so ein Zusammenbruch der russischen oder ukrainischen
Streitkräfte oder Frontlinien unmittelbar bevorsteht.
So würde ich das einschätzen.
Und ja, ich rechne aber außerdem auch damit, dass die Kämpfe weiter auf hohem
Niveau weitergehen werden.
Also ich rechne nicht damit, dass das Ganze jetzt irgendwie einschlafen wird,
sondern es wird auch den Winter über weiter durchgekämpft werden.
Und wir werden da wahrscheinlich auch leichte Vorteile wieder für die Ukraine sehen durch den Winter,
weil die russische Logistik an vielen Stellen mehr als problematisch zu sein scheint.
Und die Russen halt nicht so die Zivilbevölkerung haben hinter sich,
die dann auf ukrainischer Seite Probleme, die die Ukrainer natürlich auch haben,
dann kompensiert, was jetzt so Logistik angeht oder Versorgung mit Essen und allem.
Insofern rechne ich damit, dass die Russen weiter aufgerieben werden,
dass sie wahrscheinlich weiter dumme Dinge tun werden.
Immer wenn man denkt, okay, jetzt haben sie, jetzt scheint irgendwie Vernunft
einzukehren oder jetzt scheinen sie irgendwie eine vernünftige Strategie zu
fahren und eine vernünftige Strategie in dem Fall wäre einfach,
die Ukrainer kommen lassen und den Defensivvorteil ausnutzen und umgekehrt die
Ukrainer ausbluten zu lassen.
Aber jetzt umgekehrt so viel Material und Leute ins Gefecht zu werfen und das
gegen eine ukrainische Armee,
die über eine hervorragende Aufklärung verfügt und die über noch gute Reserven
verfügt und dann unter den Bedingungen dort,
gegen eine verstärkte ukrainische Verteidigung anzurennen, ist einfach unekonomisch.
Und die Frage ist, ich meine, hatten wir ja vorher auch so, woher kommt der Druck?
Ist das, sagen wir mal, militärischer Druck oder ist es politischer Druck?
Und mein Eindruck ist, dass das in erster Linie politischer Druck ist,
der zu dieser Offensive geführt haben und dass es keine militärische Notwendigkeit gab,
so nach dem Motto, wenn wir das jetzt nicht erobern, dann passiert irgendwie was ganz Schlimmes,
sondern die hätten das einfach so lassen können und einfach ihre Truppen erst
mal regenerieren und aufbauen und schonen,
aber das machen die Russen nicht, die fahren scheinbar auf vollem Verschleiß
und man muss sie ein bisschen auch für ihren Wagemut oder Verrücktheit oder so bewundern,
wie sie da einfach todesmutig in die Minenfelder reingefahren sind und ja,
diese massiven Angriffe und so, muss man sagen,
ja, also ängstlich scheinen sie jetzt, allzu ängstlich scheinen sie jetzt nicht
zu sein, oder Feiglinge sind die Russen jetzt auch nicht, würde ich sagen an der Stelle.
Aber ja, klug war das Ganze wohl eher kaum.
Ich meine, auch wenn es noch läuft, selbst wenn sie dieses Avdivkada erobern
sollten, so wäre das ein gutes Geschäft jetzt schon für die Ukrainer gewesen.
Und insofern, also Die russische Armee aus meiner Sicht hat teilweise gute Truppen
und hat teilweise wirklich desaströse Truppen.
Und die guten Truppen werden weniger und die unerfahrenen und eher desaströsen Truppen werden mehr.
Insofern sehe ich im Moment auch eher tendenziell, dass die Zeit immer noch
für die Ukraine spielt. spielt.
Aber umgekehrt, die Russland hat nennenswert ihre Produktion an Munition und
jetzt Importe von Granaten und so hochgefahren,
sodass das jetzt auch kein leichter Gang wird oder nicht zu erwarten ist,
dass ihnen irgendwo komplett die Munition ausgeht.
Das ist die eine Sache. Die andere Sache, über die du vielleicht noch reden
könntest, wäre das Thema Energiekrieg.
Wie wird das im Winter aussehen?
Vor allem sieht es so aus, als ob die Russen jetzt eine eigene Produktionsstraße
von diesen iranischen Shahed-Drohnen aufgebaut haben und dort also auf jeden
Fall nochmal so aussieht,
als ob diese Bedrohung durch diese relativ günstigen und zwar im Prinzip leichter
abzuschießenden Drohnen, aber die dann eben auch erstmal abgeschossen werden
müssen, dass die Bedrohung ansteigt.
Genauso wird gemutmaßt, dass die Produktion von Iskandarmissals auch hochgefahren
ist. Das wird man dann sehen. Auf der anderen Seite hat die Ukraine natürlich
auch stetig die Luftabsicherung des Landes verbessert.
Es sind weitere Systeme aus verschiedenen Ländern gekommen. Auch noch neue Patriotsysteme
aus Deutschland und aus anderen Quellen.
Also das wird im Prinzip alles besser und ich glaube die Verluste sind auch
relativ gering bisher gewesen.
Unklar, also man muss sehen, ich denke mal die Ukraine wird sich schlau vorbereitet
haben und jetzt nicht nur auf die Luftabsicherung setzen, sondern in irgendeiner
Form auch sekundäre Maßnahmen ergriffen haben.
Ich weiß nicht mit Ausfallleitungen oder keine Ahnung, also werden wir sehen
oder werden wir vielleicht auch nicht sehen.
Also man wird, das glaube ich, glaube aber auch nicht, dass die Russen in der
Lage sind wie schon im letzten Winter in irgendeiner Form die Ukraine auf diesem
Weg da nennenswert in die Knie zu zwingen.
Sicherlich wird es Auswirkungen haben, wenn solche Zerstörungen stattfinden,
klar. Aber es ist eben auch nichts, was in irgendeiner Form dafür sorgen wird,
dass jetzt die Offensiven komplett stoppen werden.
Auf der anderen Seite rüsten ja auch die Ukraine auf.
Army of Drones ist hier so ein bisschen das Stichwort. Also Ukraine setzt vor
allem so auf die Ingeniosität des Landes.
Also es gibt da einfach eine, man kann schon fast sagen, dramatische technologische
Entwicklung, die dort vorangetrieben wird im Drohnenbereich.
Hat man ja auch schon mal angesprochen, dass solche KI basierten Erkennungssysteme da mit reinkommen.
Am laufenden Meter werden neue Drohnentypen entwickelt, die mehr Reichweite
haben, die eine höhere Nutzlast, sprich höhere Bombenstärke mit sich führen können.
Es gibt jetzt neben den Kamikaze Drohnen, die also einfach durch einen Operator
direkt ins Ziel geleitet werden,
gibt es in zunehmendem Maße auch intelligente Abwurfsysteme,
also auch Drohnen, die quasi größere Granaten abwerfen und zwar nicht nur jetzt
von oben runterfallen lassen,
sondern eben auch wirklich so im Anflug, also zum Beispiel ein fahrendes Fahrzeug
verfolgt, eine Granate abwirft, aber die Drohne dabei nicht verloren geht.
Was ja dann auch mal wieder ein Aufwand ist, weil du musst dann mit jedem Angriff
wieder eine komplette Drohne wegschmeißen.
Sie produzieren die zwar mittlerweile in Massen und natürlich sind die viel
viel viel billiger als das, was damit zerstört wird, aber in jedem Bereich verbessert
sich das. Es gibt auch, hab ich auch gesehen, Mittlerweile Minenlegeroboter,
die die Ukraine einsetzt.
Also ich weiß nicht ob die autonom sind oder ferngesteuert, keine Ahnung.
Also auf jeden Fall kleine vierräderige flache Fahrzeuge, wo so ein paar Minen
aufeinander gestapelt sind.
Ein, zwei, ich weiß nicht genau, nicht viele, aber damit kann man halt strategisch
Minen platzieren, ohne selber mit Personal reingehen zu müssen.
Wir haben ja schon die Entwicklung im Marinenbereich gesehen,
also die Boote, die jetzt schon mehrfach zum Einsatz kamen und schon seit längerem
wird auch über ein Unterwassersystem gemunkelt, also nicht so richtig so eine
Submarine, sondern sozusagen so eine Art.
Aber so wie so ein U-Boot an der Wasseroberfläche arbeitet, also wo sozusagen
nur so ein kleiner Kamerakopf raus schaut, aber im Wesentlichen sich die Drohne
unterhalb der Wellen fortbewegt.
Was natürlich etwas mehr Verdrängung benötigt, aber natürlich deutlich schlechter
erkannt werden kann von angegriffenen Schiffen.
Kann gut sein, dass die auch schon zum Einsatz kamen und dass das irgendwie
auch einer der Gründe ist, warum sich die Russen so massiv zurückgezogen haben,
wissen wir derzeit nicht.
Also es ist im Wesentlichen ein Aufrüstungs-Game,
was jetzt hier parallel noch stattfindet und es ist auf der einen Seite die
Aufrüstung durch die Partner,
durch Systeme, die die Ukraine bisher nicht hatte,
in dem Zuge müssen wir natürlich auch die F-16 Flugzeuge nochmal erwähnen,
die ja zugesagt worden sind, insbesondere von Dänemark und Holland,
die ja auch, wie ich den Eindruck habe, massiv dran arbeiten,
diese Verlagerung der Flugzeuge so schnell wie möglich vorzunehmen.
Also es ist eine Situation vorstellbar, wo die Ukraine im Frühjahr nächsten
Jahres mit einer ganz anderen Flugzeugausrüstung arbeiten kann und wenn es noch
in demselben Maße gelingt,
Flugabwehrsysteme weiter so effizient zu zerstören oder an der Arbeit zu hindern,
dann können sie also ganz andere Nadelstiche setzen an den Fronten und ihre
Truppen ganz anders begleiten und absichern.
Auch Aufklärung wahrscheinlich noch auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise treiben.
Ich kenne mich da überhaupt nicht gut aus, was diese Systeme können.
Das werden wir wahrscheinlich später noch erfahren.
Das sind so die Rahmenbedingungen, unter denen sich das alles abspielen wird.
Ich bin weit davon entfernt, irgendwelche Vorhersagen zu machen,
wie das jetzt alles laufen wird. Ich bin mir nur relativ sicher,
wir werden auch weiterhin große Überraschungen, auch Enttäuschungen erleben.
Aber in der Summe bin ich da ganz bei dir.
Die Zeit arbeitet für die Ukraine, sie arbeitet nur nicht so schnell,
wie man das gerne möchte.
Grundsätzlich, wenn man jetzt nur Ukraine und Russland betrachtet,
muss die Ukraine auch für jeden,
einzelnen gefallenen drei gegnerische Soldaten töten, damit das Kräfteverhältnis
gewahrt bleibt, sage ich mal so rein theoretisch.
Insofern, die Ukraine kann sich halt nicht so viele Verluste leisten wie die
Russen und glücklicherweise aber scheinen die Russen der Ukraine den Gefallen zu tun,
dass sie bemüht sind, ja, dieses Verhältnis dann auch herzustellen.
Wobei wir wahrscheinlich, ja, also irgendwo zwischen 2 zu 1 und 4 zu 1 wahrscheinlich
Je nachdem bewegen sich die ukrainischen Verluste,
also Hälfte bis bis ein Viertel von den russischen wäre so meine Schätzung.
Was aber natürlich immer noch auch gewaltige Opfer sind, die die Ukraine da da bringen muss.
Und ja, wie vorhin auch schon gesagt, das ist ja für die Russen der blutigste
Konflikt seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Und zerstörerischste Konflikt seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg und für die Ukraine im Prinzip auch. A.
Klar. Was, sagen wir mal, zum Abschluss dann auch nochmal die Frage stellt,
was diese Länder überhaupt noch an Soldaten mobilisieren können.
Man darf sich das jetzt nicht so vorstellen, dass die Ukraine da unbegrenzte
Ressourcen hätte. hätte natürlich, gerade ein freiwilliges Engagement in der Bevölkerung ist groß.
Viele wollen sozusagen für ihr Land kämpfen,
sodass es dort ja lange gedauert hat,
bis da wirklich so eine massive Nachmobilisierung eingeleitet wurde oder überhaupt
eine Nachmobilisierung eingeleitet wurde, also man hatte teilweise eine Phase,
wo es einfach genug Freiwillige gab, aber man erstmal logistisch alles auf die Kette kriegen musste.
In Russland wiederum ist es so, allen Beobachtungen zufolge hätte eigentlich
Russland schon wieder längst eine Mobilisierung.
Rufen müssen, wenn sie quasi ihre Kampfkraft da erhalten wollen.
Diese Situation hatten wir schon mal bei der letzten Mobilisierung.
Da haben wir gesagt, das ist ja hier too little too late.
Ja, für eine Fortführung der Offensive im großen Stil war es wahrscheinlich
auch too late, aber um die Ukraine erstmal zurückzuhalten oder daran zu hindern
weiter zuzuschlagen, hat es ja dann trotz allem gereicht.
Die Russen bedienen sich halt frech einfach bei den ganzen ethnischen Minderheiten
des russischen Staatsgebietes,
weniger bei den Russen selbst, weil das ist ja dann eben dieser Konflikt,
den Putin versucht zu verhindern, weil das ist sozusagen die Stütze in der Gesellschaft.
Die Leute wollen im Wesentlichen nur Ruhe gelassen werden.
Solange Moskau und St. Petersburg glücklich sind, ist es egal,
wie sehr der Rest des Landes leidet.
Das ist natürlich auch nochmal so ein Genozid mit zwei Seiten.
Auf der einen Seite versucht man die Ukraine zu vernichten, auf der anderen
Seite minimiert man dann auch nochmal gleich die ethnischen Minderheiten im eigenen Land.
Das ist besonders perfide.
Ja, und was aber ganz gut zu funktionieren scheint,
jetzt ist die neue Rekrutierungsstrategie für Freiwillige,
haben ich auch schon beim letzten Mal erwähnt, wo sie umgestellt haben,
also das mit dem Patriotismus und so hat alles nicht funktioniert,
aber die neuen Kampagnen, die in erster Linie auf das Geld fokussieren,
was die Leute kriegen, so die scheinen zumindest ganz erfolgreich gewesen zu sein,
weil das halt unglaublich viel Geld ist, auch was die da dann draufwerfen jetzt,
also die Bezahlung ist extrem attraktiv und das scheint zu funktionieren.
Also ob sie das Geld wirklich draufwerfen oder ob sie nur behaupten,
dass sie das draufwerfen würden, da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Es gibt zahlreiche Berichte einerseits von Leuten, also die an die Front gehen und dann auch...
Sofort zu Tode kommen natürlich. Aber die, die eben auch dort länger im Einsatz
sind, klagen darüber, dass sie halt nicht bezahlt werden oder also entweder
gar nicht bezahlt werden oder ihre Boni nicht erhalten, die sie versprochen
bekommen haben oder nicht in dem Maße bezahlt werden.
Da ist sicherlich auch noch mal eine ganze Menge Korruption unterwegs,
wo solche Geldströme dann von Mittelsmännern abgegriffen werden.
Also das sind natürlich leere Versprechen in weiten Teilen, aber wenn es für
die Rekrutierung funktioniert, dann ist es ja ausreichend.
Du hast natürlich das Problem, wenn du durch Geld motivierte Leute hast,
geht die Motivation glaube ich auch nur bis zu einer gewissen Grenze.
Das ist das eine Problem. Und das andere Problem ist, wenn dir das Geld ausgeht
und du sie nicht bezahlst.
Das waren traditionell dann immer die Rezepte, wo es dann Militäraufstände gegeben
hat, weil Leute das auch nur bis zu einer gewissen Grenze mit sich machen.
Plus, dass viele Offiziere pisst sind, dass jetzt die neuen Rekruten so viel
Geld bekommen, irgendwie die Freiwilligen.
Das sorgt also auch nochmal für Unmut bei denen,
die jetzt schon länger da sind, bei den professionellen Soldaten,
dass teilweise die mehr das Dreifache kriegen von dem, was lang gediente Offiziere
bekommen und so. Ist auch nicht so nett.
Na gut, ich würde sagen dabei können wir es jetzt erstmal belassen.
Das war so unser Update zur aktuellen Situation.
Ist auch mal ganz gut sowas mal wieder vom Tisch zu bekommen,
damit wir dann auch reagieren können, wenn da was passiert. Wir werden mal schauen,
wie wir mit der Israel Sache weiter verfahren.
Wenn sich da was tut, melden wir uns sicherlich auch wieder.
Also da tut sich natürlich die ganze Zeit etwas, aber wenn wir sozusagen das
Gefühl haben, es muss jetzt auch mal wieder ein Aspekt tiefer beleuchtet werden
oder die Situation zusammengefasst werden, werden wir das auch tun.
Ja und ansonsten bleibt uns nur zu sagen,
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, vielen Dank für eure Kommentare auch,
sehr hilfreich und auch vielen Dank für eure sonstige Unterstützung,
wenn ihr UKW finanziell unterstützt.
Und damit entlasten wir euch erstmal wieder.
Ja, macht's gut.
Genau, bis bald. Tschüss.